the president is getting mixed messages
mixed reviews in fact from the media on
his inflation messaging listen
first it was transitory then inflation
is good then we went to corporate greed
now we're at putin the american people
are behind this
and more
likely are willing to take
a hit at the pump putin's price hike is
a great way to message it
fox news contributor joe koncha joins us
to break it all down and joe i would say
it's a good attempt at messaging it but
it's a lie because gas prices have been
going up month over month since he's
been in office so are people buying it
i would think so
saber so excuse me sober it's early and
same people probably are not i don't
sound silver right now uh look it's the
blame anyone else you could find at the
moment administration right carly putin
is the new trump basically uh inflation
has been rising for a year hey blade
putin uh gas prices which have been
rising since november of 2020 if you
could read a basic chart if that's your
thing blame putin uh crime blame
republicans for wanting to defund the
police no really the u.s southern border
blamed trump uh that's what they did
there disagreement at school board
meetings on how to properly educate our
kids you could blame parents that that's
a good move the debacle of the
withdrawal from afghanistan blame the
afghan military and then blame trump
just for fun it's a joke and to your
question carly nobody is laughing and
nobody is certainly buying it i would
think rahm emanuel the former chief of
staff to president obama said this after
the 2008 financial crisis you never want
a serious crisis to go to waste but
that's exactly what this administration
is doing they're using this crisis to
take accountability off themselves all
while pushing green energy and telling
everyone to buy a tesla which americans
can totally afford starting at fifty
thousand dollars a pop you know joe next
friday is the day after st patrick's day
i would expect you to be drunk then not
this morning right now right hey
speaking of speaking of sounding drunk
roll tape
is the united states willing to make a
specific allocation for ukrainian
refugees
okay
a friend in need is a friend indeed
i mean joe this is every single time now
and this has life and death consequences
how embarrassing is it that we put her
forward as our representative on the
world stage when literally life and
death is at stake
i think todd we could safely say that
kamala harris is not ever going to be an
elected president of the united states
we even had the ukrainian president
zielinski's former spokesperson tweeting
this yesterday quote it would be a
tragedy if this woman ever won the
presidency unquote and it's painfully
apparent that this is a very unserious
person in over her head again hey
there's a tweet you guys are good at a
very serious time uh trey yanks who's
one of our great no-nonsense war
reporters on the ground said it best
quote we heard this diplomatic and
political speak from vice president
harris the ukrainian people don't need
that he went on to say that her remarks
were detached from reality compared to
what he's seeing on the ground which are
horrific and kamala harris is pulling at
38 approval which you say hey that's
higher than i thought it would be yeah
that's what she's pulling in her home
state of california the bluest of flu
blue states so even many democrats right
now have biden's remorse in terms of her
being our vice president and for very
good reason guys that's right and uh
julia mendel the former press secretary
for vladimir zelinski someone we've had
on our show before she posted a tweet
about that moment where the vice
president laughed and he mentioned that
it would be a tragedy if this woman uh
won the presidency so um
a lot of people are watching her and um
that moment was certainly a huge mess
joe thank you for joining us this
morning hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now